اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من جنوب لبنان اهلا
بكم وزاره الصحه تعلن استشهاد
125 فلسطينيا خلال الساعات ال4 الماضيه
وفي الضفه الغربيه تصعيد اسرائيلي متواصل
حيث اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال شقيقتي الشهيد
صالح العرور بعد دهم منزليهما والاعتداء
على افراد عائلتيهما كما اقتحمت نابلوس
وجنين ومخيمات الجلزون والفعه والعروب
واعتقلت عددا من
الفلسطينيين القسام تعلن انقطاع الاتصال
بخليه مسؤوله عن اربعه اسرائيليين اسروا
عام
2014 وذلك تزامنا مع مظاهرات متواصله
لاهالي الاسرى في تل ابيب والقدس وحيفا في
وقت شهدت فيه جلسه مجلس الحرب تلاس بين
نتنياهو وجالت بينما طالب لبرم بتشكيل
حكومه جديده واتهم الحكومه الحاليه
بالعجز وفي الجبهه الشماليه الاعلان عن
اصابه خمسه جنود اسرائيليين في مزارع شبعه
وجيش الاحتلال يقول انه قتل اربعه مسلحين
تسللوا من الاراضي اللبنانيه بعد اشتباك
معهم في حين قال حزب الله انه قصف حشودا
اسرائيليه وحقق اصابات
مباشره غداه قصف امريكي لموقع رادار في
صنعاء جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين تقول ان
الرد على الضربات سيكون قريبا وقوي
بايدن يؤكد ان واشنطن وجهت رساله خاصه
لايران بشان هجمات الحوثيين في حين قالت
طهران ان الهجمات دليل على نجاح الضغوط
الاسرائيليه على واشنطن لجرها الى حرب
شامله الى
اللقاء